[Music]
I have said this many times you're
you're a bit of an Internet Rascal I am
yeah you're like a nice guy but you
almost have this Persona where you like
harass sports players yeah yeah and uh
Russell Crow I saw you harassing yeah he
blocked me he was like one of the first
people to block me on Twitter and I just
want to say what Cameron yeah Russell
Crow please Unblock Me it wasn't
anything personal I just thought it's
funny that you tweet your workout
regimen
you also had gret aan susten block you
that was exciting that was exciting gr
gretan ancest she's a Fox News
Personality yeah we uh we like to
torment Fox News people as
[Music]
well